I need y'all to see
this you thinking what I'm thinking I
mean maybe of course not you're not
disgusting oh let's make a funion
infused Gibson okay yeah that's it fill
a mason jar with funions then fill it to
the top with J allow it to infuse for at
least 8 hours is it weird I want to eat
a moist funion
now strange remove the solids and filter
it again with a damp coffee filter
Hannah is a home bartender with years of
experience making unique cocktail
recipes it should look beautifully clear
just like this but this one is weird and
I like weird add 3 oz of funion infused
gin to a mixing glass and add half an oz
of driver M stir with plenty of ice
strain garnish and enjoy your funion
gson